heaven is in Washington hi Devin welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks
for taking my call I really appreciate
it sure what's up so I got kind of a
typical what do I do question I kind of
have a moral issue with my job I've been
working in banking for the past five
plus years since I graduated college and
I've been a long time listening to the
show since when I was back in college
and I I know how you how you feel about
lots of careers and bankers lots of
bankers and you know I really I couldn't
agree more it's hard now with a family
when when the money is good and health
benefits are good and the vacation pay
is good and so I'm kind of just wanting
some some advice on maybe what should i
do should I make a career change should
I pick it out what is in your day-to-day
job that you feel you're being asked to
do that does not align with your yes
yeah so I'm a I'm a solutions manager
and so my job is to kind of help
relationship expansion so people that
already have a relationship with us I'm
supposed to come up with new solutions
and product offerings for them so I'm
basically you know advising people and
trying to get people to take on more
debt and that just feels you know sticky
to me okay all right would you and so
you know when you're looking at it you
say I wouldn't do this for my little
brother or my dad and so I feel weird
doing it for a customer that's correct
you would tell me you tell your little
brother don't do this and instead you're
having that's a part of your job okay
well so any time you're doing that
anywhere with any situation if you can't
feel good about what you're being asked
to provide to the customer good enough
to do it for your best friend or your
family then it is time to start looking
for a transition is it a panic no this
is not a highly toxic situation it's a
it's a values strain that's been going
on for five years and so it may take you
two or three years to make a transition
to something else once you identify what
that is and figure out what the steps
are to make that transition
and using ken Coleman's steps to to make
a transition so but I think you've
identified and Rabbi lapin our friend
Orthodox Jewish rabbi wrote the book
thou shall prosper is a good friend of
ours and he has of course a lot of
rabbinical wisdom and he says it's very
very difficult to become world class at
something that you inherently believe is
wrong hmm and so if you believe playing
football is wrong you are playing a
guitar on the stage is wrong you're
never going to be world class at it if
you believe it Bank what you're doing as
a banker in this in this situation
you're never going to be the best of the
best at it and Devin how old are you 29
so you're learning a 29 year old lesson
and this is going to carry with you the
rest of your life when you make a moral
stand when you make a value stand it
often costs you something and that's why
it's hard and that's why most people I
don't say most people that's why many
people don't have the courage and the
strength to make the hard decision what
it's going to cost you here is
discomfort if you do it gradually it's
gonna cost you money if you do it
quickly and it's gonna cost you your
soul if you don't do it at all whoa
butter boom there it is mic drop this is
the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]